some people have said we can do this
question in much the same way no we can
do this one that's true there is a bit
of a difference let me show you what we
did before and then see why there's a
problem here okay this is with the
bottles of water whatever it was okay
now what did we do I wanted to buy all
three bottles and I want to get two
liters worth of all of them okay and the
reason why that's useful is cuz then I
can compare all three prices for the
same quantity okay so that's really
important
this idea of comparison right that's the
tricky part right knowing how to compare
things okay now here it was easy because
you're like four of these is one of
these two of these is one when you look
at this there's a problem right for
example oh I can buy five of these bags
right and that'll be the same as this
but you can't buy it like you cut if you
buy - that's not equipment to this if
you buy another one it's also not
equivalent right so the numbers don't
fit quite as nicely okay so we need to
work out or what how can I compare them
look they do all have ten in common I
want and what a common sort of um I
don't want to call it factor though I
want to comment
hmm what am i after on it so it's an
important word it's a lot of common
factor it's actually a common it's the
opposite of that this is a multiple okay
and this is connected to the DeNooyer I
was I'm explaining this early before
when you're adding fractions the way
that you combine fractions is by getting
a common denominator which is I'm sorry
that's six okay like that okay so the
way you get a common denominator is
where they're common multiple so what I
want is a number grams then I can feed
all of these into okay so until like to
make a suggestion
yeah a thousand a thousand grams one
kilo right that'll fit all of these will
fit neatly into a kilo I just have to
work out how many bags do I need
so how many hundred gram bags to get to
healer the answer is 10 10 days which
means 10 times the cost 10 times 90
cents is nine dollars and okay you go to
the next one how many of these do I need
to get a kilo the answers five right so
five times a dollar seventy-five 875 now
you can see that's a better deal isn't
it but we want to keep going
and compare all of them how many of
these bags for 250 grand bags would give
you a kilo and I think that's between
double check are you guys good
the last ones are the easy half a kilo
so you just double it six dollars-eight
so now now that we have all of these for
a kilo right now these are easy to
compare right they're all comfortable
clearly you can see the best option then
um when I did it I didn't like do that
but I just loaded it straight away cuz
the difference between like two grams in
250 he's like
so I guess see the trick is that you're
doing I think a lot of the things that
are here but you're doing that mentally
and not knowing exactly what you have to
articulate which is important you've got
like this would be this would easily be
a tumor question so it's not just a tick
it's a more how do you know that's the
best option you're gonna be able to
argue it right and this is not that hard
to do I would argue that you know what
you said I worked at which always bigger
I think you're kind of doing the same
kind of maths here but I'm just showing
you okay another question okay does
anyone have any question for them that
okay all the other boards you can see I
think it's important you set up your
numbers like that and then just like
before I should conclude there are 500
gram yeah yeah you could do that we
could do that so you're thinking about
instead of a common multiple you're
thinking of a common factor the reason
why I can show you how to do it
the reason why I tend to avoid it is
because um division tends to be be
trickier but it works in exactly the
same way I'll show you
okay so let's go instead of a kilo let's
go 50 grams okay so then the question is
how many lots of 50 grams are in here
how many fifties are there the answers -
right so if I divide this by two I
should divide this by two as well that
gives you forty-five cents okay all
right how many 50s are in here
how many 50s are into grams I think the
answer is four right there are four lots
of 50 in there so I should divide both
of these by four what's the dose $35 for
I have no idea anyway calculator what is
it
when you need three and a half when you
divide through it should be 40 something
right is their decimal points 0 so 43
points yeah just give me something
I don't even cool okay so so that's
better I'm still looking for their
cheapest one right how many 50 gram Lots
are in this 5 so I'll divide this by 5
as well I think that's going to be let's
see 16 36 cents things things up cheaper
again right and this one's nice and easy
how many 50s are there there's 10 sort
to buy this through okay so you're still
doing the same thing in in the end
you're still comparing which one's the
s'mores you still end up with this as
the answer the only other issue is
division ends up with sometimes it gives
you read decimals but you can still see
which one's bigger that's the important
thing
okay so either of these will give you
the answer